all right guys
bang bang i'm here that's what you do
this guy's just bad it's just bang bang
you want to try it
that's what eddie does what who's eddie
this guy here who does like i'm starting
a podcast
after this and that's what he does bang
bang well he uh has to pay
royalties on that who was doing first uh
me obviously uh
you just hit us with bang bang real
quick no i won't do that i'm not gonna
do other people's sticks all right let's
just start
with uh you have made this grand
entrance into
uh the finance world and absolutely lit
it on fire basically just got on twitter
one day started live streaming and
basically blew up
all the scams all the whatever
why did you do it well sports was
discontinued
and i was looking for and we were slowly
getting ready to move out of the office
so i was looking for something past the
time
i mean it is gambling i like gambling
it's definitely gambling it's 100
gambling
it's just a legal casino exactly let's
walk into a casino anybody who says
otherwise
is a liar and you shouldn't trust them
um so i love gambling
and i was looking for something to do i
mean i bought a couple stocks way back
when so i had an e-trade account i think
with
twitter in it and that's it so i just
started uh
trading a couple stocks made uh uh i
didn't start with the live stream i put
on a suit pretended it was
you know my own wall street's like oh
this is interesting and people
gravitated towards it right away
um and i'm in the content business first
and foremost so it's like okay
if people are interested in doing this
i'll do it i mean we've live streamed
gambling before sports gambling and
people are into that watching you win
lose money
no different than stock market so i feel
like you have this resurgence like you
did all the content for a really long
time
then the pen deal happened you kind of
were like doing business stuff a little
bit of content
and then when the pandemic hit you just
went hard at the content again it kind
of reminded everyone like
this place is here because that's what
you did for years and years and years
right early days
yeah and so uh i think that people kind
of forgotten
that you're just a degenerate gambler at
heart and
the stock market's no different if you
treat it that way right so you know
davey pager is like that's the name from
way back like i can get paid use for
anything that's what i used to call
myself
and it really was i was all content like
that's all i did
uh maybe like a little business but once
really with the churning deal and moving
forward i
do a lot more on the business side i
don't have nearly as much time for the
content
um which i missed to a degree but
quarantine and corona when you're
isolated
in your own office there's not much
business stuff or not nearly as much
going on
yeah i got heavy into the content game
all right so i want to talk about pen
first then we'll go talk about big
stuff uh in 2016 you do the churning
deal yep
most people say horrible deal where you
sit now hindsight pretty good deal you
mean right
horrible deal in what sense like the
whole tech world is like oh my god i
can't believe you sold more than 50
of the business for like whatever but
based on what i know like
you guys pretty much needed help to
scale a business and so
would you do that deal again yeah i mean
churning it's such a interesting answer
because
and it's no different than the pen deal
to degree there were no other offers
like nobody and anybody who was
interested the conversations were
quickly shut down because
i wasn't i was making a lot of money
that maybe
personally correct i was making seven
figures and our company was doing well
and i was making more than i ever
thought
and so i had no aspirations especially
to take investor
or sell it in the churn guys kearns my
currency reached out
he was a believer in the content and it
wasn't like hey we want to change it can
you it was like you do you let's add
some fire
let's get a ceo ramp up the business
but there was i didn't have anything to
evaluate it
it wasn't like a bidding war there
weren't people knocking down if that
deal didn't happen nobody was buying it
you had to basically accept the risk
and the negative perceptions which i
think are all faults of barstool
but it is you know it wasn't a wedding
registry that's safe there was some
element of risk there
so was the valuation extremely low
yes was the first offer mike kearns made
to me insulting
yes was in hindsight it
what was that what was the first one i
think seven million seven million
valuation
yeah and you got them all the way up to
15. it was like 12 and a half
all right um but to be fair like that's
pretty good negotiation on your part
mike's not mike's no pushover when
negotiating
well i think he went so low mike i mean
currently yeah he's a professional
the turner guys are professional they're
they're super legit they know what
they're doing so if you moved it from
seven to twelve like you did pretty good
yeah it well it was so [ __ ] low and
and by the way it's like i don't
i had a number in my head i don't
negotiate so seven's like okay
i i think i was just like no i'll see
you later and then it's like well it's
gonna have to be 12 and a half and then
maybe it's back and forth and that's
what it is and kerns will probably say
that
i am probably and i'm i wouldn't say i'm
a good negotiator
but i say the price and that's it and if
you like
either we have two data points she also
did with caller daddy same thing
correct here's the price and we had a
little sticking point
with uh to be honest the pen deal and
it's like
there's i needed churning to ante
something up
and what was it i i can't get into the
details but
it got testy and
i there was one call at one point where
it's like well we split it when we do
this it's like i don't think you're
hearing me
it's like i'll walk away from everything
or it's this and but
i i also am too low now again churning
brought
credibility like expertise erica
well no i brought eric oh you brought it
yeah um
so they brought all of that to the table
they were the only so they get
credit for in huge credit for seeing it
taking the risk being the one who
offered no different than pen like
hindsight pen looks like they got
an awesome deal guess what we met with
everybody else manual draftking they
made
nobody made an offer like why are they
scared of you are they scared of the
content are they scared of just the
perception and the controversy
i think there were two major factors
scared of me controversy a b
we had worked with them for a while so i
think they kind of thought
hey we've gotten everything out of
barstool we've gotten their audience
you guys in a way built those companies
i would say absolutely
okay explain that a little bit so we
were working with the daily fantasy
companies
before draftkings existed i believe
fanduel draft street a lot of early
ones and when i say early like nascent
like they were starting
we had this big blackout tour that was a
concert tour we did and became wildly
popular and huge that was started
because draft street which was later
bought
by draftkings asked us to do a promo to
reach frat guys to get them to sign up
literally and uh draftkings i sat with
like jason robbins and all the
owners probably a decade ago in
nantucket or something like that and
they offered me equity in the company
because we do these contracts and pit
fanduel draftkings versus each other and
the highest bidder
and they go back it was a war because
they were so effective now
did you take the equity net did not take
the equity why
the main reason was i couldn't i was so
focused barcelona and there was i
thought
there's gonna be too much going on where
i sit in the room and i didn't totally
understand it but it's like i didn't
envision
um wanting to sit in a room every week
and have these meetings
like i was concentrating on barcelona um
and i didn't totally understand the
equity portion of it
in hindsight i don't know which way it
would have worked out better like i
could have done this deal
um but i obviously would have had a
small percentage and i don't
understand dilution and all that [ __ ]
what it would have ended up with um so
we worked with them throughout
but as barcelo grew and that as that
space became more competitive
we started and this is something i never
did back in the day one ad will be in
mgm casino the nexus fanduel the nasa
draft chain is the nexus point bet
it's just being whitewashed just like
how it is if you watch a football game
now and there's 10 commercials do you
pay attention to
any of them probably not so i don't
think any of the companies we're meeting
with realized
well when we were bought or acquired or
focus
our energy just on one company what will
happen it changes the game the narrative
everything so i think they underestimate
that i think they were a little bit
scared but they could have gotten us
fanduel specifically and could have
gotten us for far cheaper i think than
pending to be honest all right and they
missed the vote so you do the churning
deal yeah
uh i remember talking to erica in 2017
she laid out this vision we were joking
earlier like to the point where it was
almost
is that even possible right like hey
we're going to the moon type thing
uh i wrote this piece and said uh you
guys were i think it was a 15 million
dollar evaluation
or 12 12 and a half i always said
because charlie didn't want to say what
it was so i would always say 10 to 15
but it was 12 and a half okay all right
well you probably shouldn't say the x
exact number now well it doesn't matter
now except people be like you idiot i
think i may turn like a quarter million
or something like that no big deal did
he buy you dinner
no we haven't we he has offered he has
offered
oh you just didn't go i don't know that
chernin's
giving me anything like not even like
maybe a thank you card couple nice
emails maybe
i like those guys but they haven't i
don't think they like hey they're
waiting they're waiting until you make
them a billion and they're
they're a great job you may as a cool
you return a nine gazillion
that was a unicorn investment for them
okay so
uh i wrote this piece and i said
barcelona's gonna be a billion dollar
brand
if basically you don't sell too early
right right and the whole idea was just
you have
the fan base and it was so obvious early
on like if you have the relationship
with the fans
you win because you can create companies
sell it through products sell it through
whatever
at some point you decide one to sell
right a piece not nothing but a piece
and then two you do it where now you're
focusing all your energy on somebody
else's product it's not something that
you guys created talk through like why
do that versus just go start your own
sports book plus a bunch of other stuff
and put it through the
distribution you mean here with like pen
with pen well we could never start our
own sports book we'd never get licensed
we'd never get access
we all that [ __ ] would just never happen
so um
you needed the partner to needed the
partner and they were the perfect
partner and again
it is a question i get asked a lot but
when you're in our shoes and i've been
[ __ ] grinding at this thing for 17
years
um you know i made money but
in it's all relative like i i'm
obviously have done well
but when you look at the churning deal
it's not like i was obscenely rich like
i had money but that wasn't like oh my
god
and even now it's not like now where you
can tweet at celebrity network
hey correct 200 million right um on
paper
uh but so this what and there are
it's not as if we have this waterfall
of offers and meetings when you're going
through and
you nobody's making an offer it's like
well is anyone get an offer and as
do i want to do this for the next 20
years to build it up
i always thought sports gambling is how
we started the second
the legislation the united states
changed to make it legal
i'm like okay this is our moment and we
spent close to a year
trying to figure out the best fit and
penn was
by far and away the best partner that
presented itself from
jay snowden who i love the ceo to them
understanding what we do and having
faith and believing in it
um there was it it was almost a
no-brainer i mean we named our price
there was no negotiation with penn and i
thought it was crazy because based on
how did you call it with the price i
didn't like the you know the tr
and the churning guys as you said
are fierce negotiators so if they're
naming it i'm like okay
but they named it and and penn was like
yep that's it
done they didn't negotiate was nothing
as long as they felt
we were aligned and we are because it's
not like i got paid it's like
a lot of stock and all that [ __ ] how
much did you take in stock versus cash
it was like
it it was uh 5545 55 uh casher stock
55 stock 45 and that's like different
for me
it's like the barcelo people are
different than the cherokee yeah yeah so
i mean it it was a great deal now when
the stock goes up and bumps pre-corona
you know it's like oh we should dump we
just made them a gazillion dollars in 10
seconds
because wall street reacted obviously
super favorably to the deal
and that's when the other companies we
met with who i like like i uh
obviously it's like the brady six when
he's crying like i get a chip on my
shoulder like i'm meeting with these
guys who know us it's like you're not
gonna make an offer you're [ __ ] an
idiot and they've probably had to spend
on talent now more than they would have
spent just to buy us
because we put them in a box it's like
oh [ __ ] well what is it fanduel did the
pat mcafee deal right
yep on top they're doing well all of
them
yes because like okay and they could
have
they missed and i don't know if they'd
say they missed you but they miss
because i actually really like the
fanduel guys and the ones running it
it's like if they made an offer that was
competitive like okay we can win with
these guys i feel like everyone in the
gambling sports fantasy world are people
like barstow
right like the type of person is so
similar so the people who are running
those companies
there's a very cultural fit with what
you guys have done ooh
maybe not not at the top okay that's
different
yeah maybe down below but that's why
we're gonna be like i i've met with them
all
they don't they're they're not like how
bad does this get in the sense of fast
forward five years
the barstool sports book versus all
these other guys
like how bad of a massacre is it oh i
don't know because they have such a
gigantic
lead they have great tech they have a
huge lead um
and there's no industry that i'm aware
of where there's like one guy i mean it
doesn't matter what there is there's
multiple players and they're competitive
and
in a way it can help each other but
nobody outside like i guess the cable
company and telephone well even there's
model but
you can only get one cable company in
your house other than that
there'll be multiple players like
fanduel and draftkings are not going
anywhere yeah
we're we're different like those two
to me are
one of those i don't know what'll happen
though they're identical companies to me
they're both out of the daily fantasy
the big databases they're gonna try to
win with
offers and plays no one cares no one's
gonna wear a fanduel hat or draft as
much as they try that's never gonna
happen
but they're they're gonna be there we
and i saw one interesting stat when i
was looking at downloads and it's like
it didn't our downloads and what we did
in pennsylvania
and handle all that didn't seem to take
away from the others and i can believe
that
oh interesting so it was additive to the
correct because we have our audience who
makes sense have been so you know it
could help
both markets i could and who knows i'm
anybody who thinks i've inside we talked
insider knowledge like you came in and
i'm like well pen was down 10
they did this stock offering i had no
idea that was coming and i have
so much pen stock even beyond like
you know why they don't tell you right
because it's our trading no no because
telling you wouldn't be bad because
you're an employee but then you'd
then you would
so they basically know you better than
you know yourself they protect me but
it's still
so they told me just late last night so
i wouldn't
be like stunned by the news well i'm so
confident
in myself and what we do here that i
just keep buying it as it goes like i'll
bet on myself 100 so when he told me
that
i would never know this if i wasn't
doing the day trader like oh
stock's going to get killed like not
because pen anytime
a company does this stock is killed i've
seen it like i've owned stocks i'm like
what the [ __ ] is it down and people like
oh they did an offering
it doesn't generally last it comes back
but when he told me that
it's like i'm sitting here with i'm like
all right you [ __ ] like
i'm tomorrow and it's like i have to
wake up all these people
and sure enough it did they buried some
good stats but
yeah it's uh hold on before we talk
about the stock stuff you guys launched
the sports book
in pennsylvania this past weekend you
outperform
downloads for all the other ones did you
guys have to spend money to drive that
or is that all organic just putting it
through the dishwasher
which to me which is the big advantage
that you guys have yeah so
that is the story and that's why
even the way they did this release if
they can't tell me like the press
release and all that
i feel like they should talk to me
because i'm understand marketing i feel
like better than they do
like it's stock offering and then at the
bottom it like had the stats
in the stats and people twist them
people don't like me will say they're
bad they're good
it's like i think i have it's like 30
000 yeah it's like 30 000 downloads
downloads in pennsylvania
11 million handle like 24 000
registrations
is really really impressive there's 10
existing companies
sportsbooks in pennsylvania with a huge
lead on us
we know where it's like a race that is a
a
10 mile race and the other companies are
are five miles in and we're just
starting
there's no other company in the world
who could have that dent with zero
dollars spent
we didn't spend a cent so how and
when you guys go to market this how much
is this just you send a message to
everyone here you're like hey we're
launching this like
you know go promote it versus it's uh
specifically like okay we're gonna
promote it on this show we're gonna
promote it on this show like how should
i
teach
it's pretty just promote it however like
you see fit that's what it looks like
which makes it so much more valuable yep
and that that is how it is and it's a
natural
because our history is gambling and then
i was saying like extrapolate it
you know take a state like michigan
where it is not legal yet
and that's like i went to school there
we're huge in the midwest
penn has one of the nicest casinos there
that the greek which is
like i think their nicest las vegas
style casino
and all of a sudden everyone's at the
starting line at the same time
well we're going to cause real damage
there so not everyone's totally
understanding that i guess some people
do some people don't
but pennsylvania was as encouraging i
think as
we could possibly expect it to be and
like the stock offering thing
again like we're not unless i'm being
strictly lied to which i know i'm not
that's money is not going to people's
hands or using it as it was i said
to give me like guns ammunition so we
can start spending
so i i feel like uh this is external
looking
in if somebody just gives you a camera
and says go live stream
you'll win some portion of the market
right you big cat et cetera like
whatever
then when they put a company that's got
real technology behind you right okay
now the product actually works it's good
great and then if they put marketing
dollars behind this as well
it's like it's unbeatable 100 and
i think there'll be consolidation again
this is just a yes in the market
like if you took a fanduel or draftkings
and combine them with us
that's the end of that's the end of this
game do you want that to happen
depends how much money you'd get like
honestly that's all yeah that's a great
answer though yeah that's all a finance
thing like who's in control i know this
like if those two combined doesn't
matter it's the same company who cares
they probably have a very similar they
tried already
yeah and they have a very similar
database it's like i guarantee you
almost everybody who has fanduel has
draftkings and vice versa
and they're shopping lines they do where
did so we are a very different thing
we combined with one of those the other
one's dead so i like that position
and it could happen in the world then
you look at things like mgm grand shout
out i mean whatever they had jamie foxx
i don't know if you saw no they they
signed him like a big jamie foxx he's
the face of mgm gambling with an app
it's like are you kidding me jamie fox
versus dave poor knowing the gambling
space
that that that is a beat down like that
isn't it by the way by the way they have
real production studios etc and you're
basically sitting on
uh you know in your backyard and the
[ __ ] hamptons or whatever
right and the nutty thing is like i know
mgm and i know caesars and we talked to
them and they'd never do a deal with us
because there's old stuffy suits and
whatnot
i've never heard of pen ever until like
a lot of their uh properties were
different names like i heard a pen
national
like casino i knew the tropicana which
is a dump which they had owned at the
time
but like i never knew what they are go
ask people now who pen is it's like
everybody knows
everybody knows suddenly it's like you
look at the casino groups that's all
barstool
um it's funny because i know i'm
underpaid again like
i was underpaid with churning i realized
i didn't how did you structure the deal
now that you did that deal you obviously
got cash in stock yeah right
your five-year deal i have a five-year
contract here okay and you
you get stock in cash correct okay and i
can like
i'm basically they tied me in the long
term like are and if it goes better you
probably get more
if it doesn't go so well then well my
stock is fluid i can't sell it
so it's like do you do they treat you
like an athlete where uh
you know hey if you hit 20 home runs you
get a bonus or anything no
no um and i this is where
my lack of negotiating skills probably
comes in i
generally don't like renegotiates like
all right
i like the deal now no don't read
negotiation the churning guys were
essentially
at currents like yeah you were underpaid
the whole time i was like no [ __ ] i was
like they did give me raises
but uh you know when you see
did you ever when you were handing out
newspapers at the uh subway and train in
boston do you think you were ever gonna
have a boss
no and i still don't i still
don't i do but i don't because all right
explain
well i have technically a boss
jay snowden and i guess you churning
guys are as well
yeah but they let you do your thing
well when the ultimate trump card is i'm
just going to walk away if you don't
give me what you want
and your business is going to fall apart
i don't have a boss are you negotiating
with jay and chernin right now no no
i i don't do it that way i i nev it's
like
whether erica i'm pretty sane like our
interests are aligned and i'm honest i'm
straightforward and as long as you're
back to me we'll never have a problem
and i would never do a deal with jay
or turn in if i thought that was going
to be an issue but
our business strangely enough
is so dependent on the content whatever
it literally
when the ultimate card and i'm i am
crazy enough to walk
like i know i know but it's like on
principle
if you're like okay you to be honest
from afar if there was ever a okay
here's the moment
and it was give back the 200 million
dollars or like
concede to whatever [ __ ] i literally
think you'd give back the most
a hundred percent which which is by the
way is [ __ ] insane yeah that that
that would be the easiest if it was
something
where i'm like this is wrong i can't do
this or
you're [ __ ] me over i would rather
the entire
ship burn with me then like
then then concede it's just in my nature
you know that's why mgm and caesars and
all them couldn't do a deal with you
probably
probably but it's true but it boils down
to
it when i say it's like honesty and
being straightforward
and you may not like it but i i would
never go into business with somebody who
i didn't have the vibe like there i
don't care if i
it's not whether i like something or
don't like something
it's whether i feel like you're being
deceitful or misleading that's where i'd
be like
no you you said that i remember the
churning deal
there was like 50 grand in
lawyer fees that i know at the beginning
it's like they cover
my lawyer fees it was 50 grand i was
getting a lot of money for me at the
time
and we were like the last moment like
yeah you pay for the lawyer fees i mean
no we agreed that you did
and not mike someone else called and
they tried to negotiate it
and i literally at the end i'm like the
deal's off it's like
i don't they're like we'll give you 40
not 50 i'm like it's 50 or the deal is
off because we agreed on it
that's it if we agree on something with
me you better [ __ ] honor it or else
i will walk and you do the same in
return totally right okay
all right so over the last couple of
months you've been yelling and screaming
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] like stocks only
go up right now going down right now
well hold on
but most people think dave porno is an
idiot he doesn't know what he's talking
about he knows nothing about finance
blah blah whatever
you've actually been right you don't
know why you've been right probably but
you're actually right and the reason why
it only goes up is because they're
literally just
creating [ __ ] money so i wanted
exactly so
that's what i want to talk about kind of
insulting that you said i don't know why
i mean i've done the shirt box thing
so that video is probably one of the
most real
honest evaluations of the stock market
and the economy
right than anything anyone will watch on
television right and the whole idea is
basically
this everything was selling off the fed
steps in they pump a bunch of money into
the economy and it just [ __ ] shoots
up
right like literally 50 60 off the
bottom whatever while that's going on
you start screaming stocks only go up
and i think everyone's uh reaction and
finance is so visceral to like what does
this guy know he doesn't know but
whatever but you're right
right and so like talk just about the
experience of
all these people in susan taj yelling
and screaming dave fournette doesn't
know he's talking about
one you've been right two you're right
structurally and three there's no end in
sight for them to stop doing this [ __ ]
right and i mean if you look long term
the only one thing i have said was like
if you're an old person whatever and you
need to get your money out you got to be
a little more careful but if you're
if you can wait if you're 25 if you're
gonna outweigh the stock market
you can always outweigh the stock market
it'll always go up it doesn't matter how
far
down it goes if that's just a fact if
you look at it but yeah the suit you
know it's an industry that i've never
been involved in
i don't think they had ever and i've had
this happen a lot during the course of
barcelona they just didn't know what to
do with me
it's like you know you the guy you said
raw scurvy is like hey come on my
podcast i don't like them like suck my
dick like you know they don't know
it's like okay like how do i respond to
that well he deleted the tweet that's
how he'd respond to that
and they'll chirp me from the cheap
seats when things are going on but i
don't care that's like
i like that that that's my world they're
playing into the game correct
you want to talk [ __ ] they the way they
talk [ __ ] is not actually talk [ __ ] they
basically
like throw these little intellectual
zingers and you're just like yeah let's
just full-on
let's just go at it and for any time i'm
on tv or mentioned
it's good i mean as crazy it is it
really
when it exploded was when i started
making fun of warren buffett
but the financial community and there
may be by the way you're not wrong
with his performance he has to beat the
s p over the last 90
years old people like if you're in your
prime at 90
then you were never good before no one
gets sharper at 90. i can't remember
what i had for breakfast
so you know they took a quote because it
all started with the airlines basically
cruising airlines
i was getting killed i had shorted i was
getting murdered and and
part of it's like wait a minute the
stock market is not connected at all to
what's going on in the world we're in
this pandemic
shit's going on stocks go up down
whatever but i said i'm going in on
airline spirit was at seven
and literally i did this big rant and
like five minutes later
warren buffett comes out with a press
release it's like we're we're getting
out of the airlines
at the bottom of the market correct and
it was literally i said go in on
airlines
two seconds later he says get out do you
think he was watching the live stream i
i don't i wonder if he actually knows
who i am i doubt it
but so after that stock the the airlines
went
ballistic yep parabolic as the crypto
people like to say
and then you know that uh one of my
business partners he's got
jason williams yeah i know who he is
yeah he's got he's got a youtube channel
called going back
we started yelling parabolic yeah it's a
great word yeah
that's like a crypto they should just uh
trademark that word that's a very good
word
so it went nuts and then i'm like oh
warren buffett sucks i'm the captain now
and like investing.com and business and
start took that quote
and then from there it was kind of game
over ran and i did notice like cnbc they
liked having me on a lot more when i was
losing
yeah and when i started winning it's
like they stopped having me on and they
didn't want to talk about it but it's
also the type of content like it's the
memes it's the live streams it's like
all this stuff that they don't really
know how to
deal with right and part of what's so
funny and when you started
playing around with bitcoin and crypto
like you realize immediately like holy
[ __ ] these people just meme the hell out
of anybody
community very very impressive meme
community
so that's why the mainstream media is
like what do we do with these people
right because they're literally it's a
suit anonymous account that's just
throwing out crazy memes and there's
like what the [ __ ] is yeah that's my
that's
so i have nothing in crypto right now
that is probably the thing i miss the
most is the memes
oh i like the link marines i think are
dead
they are did you kill them well what
what is it at now
eight i mean or did you all right so all
right let's back up for a second
let's talk about bitcoin first i don't
know why you bought anything else other
than just bitcoin
because the link marines were blowing up
my thinking about link link marines it's
like i see other [ __ ]
it's no different from the stock market
everyone's pumping their own [ __ ] all
right
what questions do you have about bitcoin
eight look at that 890 when'd you buy it
so i bought it
at i think 14 it went to
19 i sold it at 16. oh so you made money
then
about even yeah uh what well bitcoin
you want to see the 2007 bitcoin
is a in my mind just one big ponzi
scheme okay why
the 2017 video you have by the way
bitcoin marty says hello
that [ __ ] bitcoin marty he's part of
first of all all the people i know in
bitcoin bitcoin marty
bubbly gang our people caleb that caleb
yeah he told me to stop bash he's like
yeah
yeah he came on he came he understands
it now
i understand what i think you guys think
it is
to me it is a ponzi scheme that you get
in
and and you just gotta not be the one
held left
holding the bag i'm going to give you
ammo for the finance world and then i'm
going to tell you why bitcoin's the
solution
well i know what it is it's gold and
pumping money and they're set i mean
the stock market you know it always goes
up it's like that 45 degree angle
correct
since 1971 direct 45 degree angle a
couple of drops whatever but it's
straight up that's because it's
denominated in dollars they're just
devaluing the dollar right
stocks go up if you denominate that same
stock market in gold
the stock market is down since 1971.
it's all
the stock market is a complete scam in
terms of accruing value it's all the
dollar being devalued
so it goes straight up 45 degree angle
but if you denominate it in ounces of
gold
it's down okay so
okay well here's a different language
no here's why it's important uh you
bought a house right
in uh where uh a lot of places
nantucket yeah i have one there yes okay
why'd you buy that house in nantucket i
love that place
okay a lot i mean i loved it is that
that's not something i was trying to get
like i thought i'd live there the rest
of my life okay and there wasn't that
many to select from
right yes okay and because there's not
that many the prices are expensive and
you have a lot of money so you could buy
right yes
okay same thing in the digital world is
there some things that are just scarce
and if those things end up having a
large community that wants them
what ends up happening the price goes up
go up correct okay so bitcoin's only got
21 million obviously
and the whole thing behind it is the
strongest computing power in the world
so literally the computer network that
runs bitcoin is stronger than anything
in the world no government nobody can
hack it because it is the strongest
computing network in the world it's got
more computing power on it than anything
else
the reason why that's so important is
because the
whole idea of like why does barstool
work it's because you guys are
completely decentralized like nobody
if they try to like come at you they get
attacked by all these other people at
barcelo
right and that decentralized type media
model where you're not going and telling
somebody okay send me your thing i'm
going to be the editor and then like i'm
going to approve it
it's just like here's a [ __ ] camera
go post on your accounts and like just
blow it up right and do it that's the
same type of thing that's going on
but with money now so rather than the
government saying uh hey today we're
going to print more money or
remember what happened today with penn
where they just all sudden all these new
shares right
you're like [ __ ] what the hell like i
had no say in this right that's
basically what the federal reserve does
so earlier this year they printed three
plus trillion dollars
you didn't get a vote i didn't get a
vote as [ __ ] okay
whatever cash you have so let's say
you're worth 200 mil and let i don't
know
30 million dollars in cash right that 30
million of cash if you leave it in cash
it's gonna be worth less next year worth
less next year right because the
purchasing power goes down
and so what ends up happening is you're
financially incentivized to get out of
the dollar
and buy stocks buy gold but you know buy
[ __ ] property whatever
but with bitcoin they can't do that
because there's only 21 million and a
computer runs it so the only way to
change the computer is if
more than half of the people agree to
change what the computer does
so there's no person there's no like old
guy in a suit who basically is like i
think that we should print more money
or ah you know what we should take some
money in circulation no human is
involved in making the decision
it's the consensus of everyone involved
so
the reason why it becomes so valuable is
because nobody can [ __ ] with it
and that's why the bitcoiners are so
like rabid about it is they're just like
it doesn't matter what anybody says what
you think i think anybody
nobody can [ __ ] with it and because it's
like that
on the internet and globally everyone's
subjected to the same rules
it continues to accrue value because
people realize wait a second they're
[ __ ] with the dollar they're [ __ ]
with the euro they're [ __ ] with the
yen the r b
whatever but the only thing you can't
[ __ ] with is bitcoin and so
as that keeps going you should just take
one to five percent
of your net worth put in bitcoin don't
look at it just leave it there
and that'll be the best performing thing
in your entire portfolio
if you take one percent out of
everything else in your portfolio
whether you own real estate stocks
anything what's one percent gonna give
me
well let's say it goes up 20 x
what's one per what's one percent of 200
million i don't have a 200 million but
was one percent so a million dollars
i make 20 million and what how long so
there's something called the having i'm
sure that they've all told you about
this but basically the whole idea is
every four years the amount of bitcoin
that shows up every day
it's cut in half so it used to be 50
bitcoin a day or
50 bitcoin every 10 minutes then was 25
bitcoin every 10 minutes and 12 and a
half now it's at 6.25
that just happened in may it got cut in
half again every time that that's
happened
the next 18 months bitcoin's gone up an
incredible amount because it's a
supply shock right it's like think of it
as uh if we all wanted
something and then what is even bitcoin
at right now like 10
500.
do you remember when you first started
buying it well i bought way back
in the day yeah what was the price more
than that
was over ten thousand yeah i think so i
bought it in that huge rush when
everyone was yeah but it was only it was
only above 10 000 for like
20 or 30 days so you would have to
really have bad timing i thought it was
close to like 20.
it went to it went from 10 000 to 20 000
in 18 days in 2017. so i probably bought
around 15 or 16.
okay you still have it or you saw it's
lost
it was in one of those keychains you
lost it yeah
that was another part it's like i don't
i don't like having to hold [ __ ] in like
keychains and weird
and like uh marty how much how much did
you have
probably 50 grand marty like had to do
it
yeah yeah yeah he he helped you and then
he gave it he gave you the he gave me
something with the weirdest company he
lost like yeah it's gone
okay so i lost that but i i'd be down on
that
and that was what 2017. yeah but you got
to remember but you got to understand
that the markets the way that they work
is so that having happens
it goes up a bunch in prices or supply
shock usually it takes about 18 months
for that to happen
then it draws down 85 percent it's
happened three times already yeah right
well
the thing why i say it's like so i got
out i i really
this latest round i think i had 1.25
million in it at one point
it went up went down and then went back
and i was like i absolutely don't know
what the [ __ ] this is and it's too much
money to not
like at least with stocks even though i
don't believe half the [ __ ] they say
like okay our stock got tanked today i
can do a direct
like line do we do the stock offering i
know why or
earnings or and what i don't like i
think a lot of is [ __ ] i think the
day to day like
but i understand it's like almost like
watching a sports game like all right my
team lost i bet a minus two they lost by
three i lose my money
bitcoin i'm no [ __ ] like there's no
rationale why is it going
i have no idea why so enough think of
like a uh a technology company right
when barcelona first started actually
it's a great idea
you didn't have a stock price right
correct so it was just every day the
only person who saw the
p l or whatever it was if you guys even
had one right right and
if there was a stock price in the early
days of barstool it'd be like in the
morning it would be through the roof
right by the afternoon to be down and it
was basically like what you emotionally
felt there's highs there was lows
it was like super volatile you're like
are we gonna [ __ ] survive are we not
whatever
super super volatile but because you're
a private company
there's no stock price so if you think
of bitcoin
it's really a technology right and has
that same volatility that barstool had
or other
tech companies have it's just that
there's a price associated with it so
what you're seeing is you're seeing all
that incredible volatility
but like imagine if uber the first
couple of years
but what is that what is that based on
emotion right now no well well it's
price discovery right so think if you
think of bitcoin people are buying and
selling bitcoin
to me did you hear about this guy mike
uh micro strategy what he did microsoft
i saw that in my travels but i didn't
like research it but it was pop
popping up like his 500 million dollars
on his balance sheet
publicly traded company over a billion
dollar valuation he took 85
425 million dollars of out of dollars
and put it in bitcoin
and the reason he said is if i leave
this in cash it's going to get devalued
so every year that i sit with this cash
it's going to be worth less and less and
less
so i moved it to bitcoin now that's a
really really aggressive move
right of course but if you think about
from a personal perspective
one every investment you make you want
asymmetry
right if you if you think about the best
investors in the world they're right
like 55 60
at the time so all these guys who are
like all right every time they're all
[ __ ] fortunate right well
whoever right they're all foolish yeah
the absolute
best investors in the world right 55 to
60 time but they only put
trades on where it's like i can lose 10
or i can make 20 times my money right so
asymmetric in their favor
that they're willing to take kind of the
losses 45 of the time
because the 55 percent time they're
right it just pays for it
right so what you want to do is create a
portfolio of
assets that have asymmetry right so penn
stock has asymmetry
in a sense it's not going to go to zero
right it can go up a lot bitcoin
has asymmetry in that yeah maybe it
drops down but it drops 10 20 percent
but it also can go to you know hundreds
of thousands of dollars right
and then what you want is you want a
bunch of stuff that's non-correlated so
if you have penn stock and then six
other stocks and they're all
moved together so when pen goes down
they go down well then just put it all
in [ __ ] pen stock why do you have all
six of them right because they all move
together
but what you want is you want different
types of assets so you want bitcoin you
want pen stock you want whatever
and then what ends up happening is if
pen stock's down that doesn't
necessarily mean that bitcoin is up or
down there's just no correlation
although bitcoin lately
seems to be tied to what's going on the
stock market good observation
so in liquidity crisis right and since
march basically the reason why the fed
pumps so much money in is because
everyone
[ __ ] panics and says like to me my
original gut was
if you asked me before like
this would be beneficial to bitcoin but
it hasn't been it's the best performing
asset this year
like from an asset class it's up like 60
percent when you say asset
so think stocks precious metals crypto
like whatever right so yes there are
individual stocks that perform better
than some but as a whole
stocks are basically up single digit
percentage from year to date
gold's up like 20 25 bitcoins up over 50
right so it's outperformed all the other
ones on like a asset class basis
and the whole thing is uh they're
pumping all this money people are scared
of inflation they run to inflation hedge
asses precious metals real estate
whatever
but bitcoin's the most volatile and so
it dropped 50
a single day earlier this year like
right scares the [ __ ] out of people
right but then when everything goes up
it just goes up more than everything and
that doubly scares the [ __ ] out of
people i think
and and part of my i know what you're
saying like what sakashi or whatever the
[ __ ] this guy
is it there's nobody count i'm an
accountability guy
so like nicola you know that guy was a
fraud and he's like
i like knowing even if you stole my
money i like knowing who stole it
i can be like this [ __ ] guy so you
see i think he'd delete his twitter
account
he did he did yeah he got out he got
called out and
so to me is that what's worse losing
your job or having to delete your
twitter account
like would you rather get kicked out of
barstool or have to delete your twitter
account
i mean i have no problem deleting i'll
just come outside michael paper
michael scott paper company i got like
lots of names i can do so i'm not
worried about that
but you know that's part of the thing is
bitcoin
and i get like i understand what you're
saying but still
there's an unease and maybe it's i also
have a like
i don't put my toe in the water yeah i
generally like
jump in like all right i want to make
like 10 grand i don't know if i can do
that i want to put
millions into something like if you
looked at what i'm doing right now
like that's why i got caught with my
hand in the cookie jar with my own
[ __ ] company
it's like but that's how i operate so
not knowing being like
do you think penn stock or bitcoin
performs better through the end of next
year
that's a tough one but it makes you
think well no it makes me think because
i
if you told me a month ago that penn was
going to be like 75
i'd be like that's crazy like we're not
going like i i was happy when it hit
like 40. i bought in at
like 20 so i don't it's an interesting
one because it was not only just penn
the we we've hit and you could look back
we've hit a legalized vice so i don't
think people truly know
the market of what we're in and one of
the things i keep hearing whether it's
penn
whether it's draftkings anybody which i
have a
bananas disagreement with is and i
haven't really said it
people keep saying the sports book is a
gateway drug it goes to on
ai casino all the money all the money is
in my casino
and i think but that's what everyone
says yeah but but that's stupid because
it's literally a completely different
experience and if you're a degenerate
sports gambler you want to do that you
don't want i [ __ ]
but the margins are better on online
yeah of course and like
a picture down the road if we have
online blackjack and i'm talking i'm
dealing and like that's something people
can't but are they there for you are
they there for the black
like how many of the stoolies want to go
play
what they for most young kids are
probably going to assume is a rigged
online gambling
i see i don't think penny and major
companies i don't think they're going to
think they're raped i i really
like if you're some for the online
gambling yeah like the actual like
casino
correct and and if it's set up in
in a world where at halftime hey go play
blackjack for like i think you can do it
my point is different
i look at because a lot of the brick and
mortars pen include is like our sports
books don't make a ton of money people
want it to value
go look at casinos how big are the
sports books most of them how much real
estate do they take up
not that much because they're like it's
not the money makers the tables and
things like that
but i equate it and i think this will be
something that people aren't factoring
in
to online poker and poker if you go to a
casino poker rooms don't make money they
don't
online poker made a [ __ ] on because
there's no walls so the problem
it i've always thought and it's no
different with sports books
you need physical space how many people
can you put in a sports book not that
many
but if you run your sports book
correctly and you have
50 50 and you're just getting juice and
unlimited walls
that juice should be just like the poker
that's taken the rake
should be wildly well you guys are also
promoting it in a way that
the entire space has never seen before
totally different everything we do will
on its head even the prop i had
yesterday
i don't know it's like like you can win
a jacket if you do this
oh all this [ __ ] that you guys are
do like by the way it's genius marketing
but they are shook because they don't
understand like they don't have the
personalities to go do this jamie foxx
is not going to be like
hey if you do this bet we're going to do
some crazy
not only that jamie foxx and i like
jamie foxx he doesn't give a [ __ ]
well it's like jane fox has so much
money and is doing so many things
you think he really cares about pushing
mgm's sportsbook and even if you look at
the deals which i never
understood um if you go to foxbet or
terry bradshaw these guys
work for the network they don't like my
life is in this and a lot of our guys
here this
this is it like if this [ __ ] thing
tanks then i basically
[ __ ] myself on how i sold it so i'm not
guaranteeing
that it works but when you invest and
pen or do this or pen invest in us
you're getting like my best shot and my
only shot really
so it's a huge difference and and i love
pat like i taught
pat how to [ __ ] gamble a guy never
plays a bet literally until three years
ago
and he's a jack-of-all-trades so
talented but he's doing a lot of [ __ ]
things
this is it i have like laser focus and
at the very least
they got my action which is a lot of
action and i always lose are
are you moving to philadelphia so i am
in philadelphia now
i have to be here wednesdays because we
film all day
and then i head back well we do the show
with dion
so generally on thursdays so wednesdays
i'm in the office filming
thursdays generally we can't deal on
schedule now because the job is all over
the place and by friday i'm back in
philly till tuesday
so it's like 4 3. okay tell me how the
dion sanders deal happened
so by the way epic epic get dion
is a thousand percent better than i ever
thought he would be he fits perfectly
like you can
literally say whatever the [ __ ] you want
to him he gets it
he knows he's busting balls he doesn't
take offense um
so we were were you worried that he
might yes yeah
like hall of famer he made a lot of the
athletes famous athletes or even
personalities we've dealt with
do not fit in they come from first of
all network people
and people who have money don't have the
work ethic we do we're born from the
internet the only way people find out
who you are
is because you're better funnier worked
harder than other people that's it
that's the culture here um if you have a
lot of money
you're an athlete you've been told
you're the best your whole life you may
have a very different like work ethic
than we do
um so we we have a podcast out of philly
uh million dollars worth a game amazing
most underrated podcast there is they're
hilarious hilarious
so they're friends with dion um and of
course they are
and they're like hey he's looking and he
they did the introduction
and we went to uh to barstool yeah to
erica and i
we flew down met with him it's like what
do you want um
it seemed like a good fit there was a
lot going on
it's one of those things combo he's
expensive we were willing to pay
it was a good look for us we had the pen
deal going on so it's like football show
but he's awesome he's better than in in
everything's like
credibility as well like okay we can
compete with these big guys
but he's been i don't know how he's
going to continue it
with the job but he is for those that
don't know he just what jackson
is he the head coach yeah head coach did
you see his press conference uh i saw a
clip of i didn't see it it's insane
it looked like someone said it looked
like coming to america it did he had
like
this caliber raid of like cars coming to
the gym like people dropping
it was very prime time but he's not
super prime time off camera yeah like he
is but he isn't like he's
a guy like that obviously you know
if i'm with someone younger and like
deon sanders they may like who's that
mike
really it's like to me he's like he was
it two three
most famous guys like bo jackson dion
sanders like
they're it um you ever heard of anybody
playing in a football game in a baseball
game in the same day
but but in the [ __ ] you can say so i
didn't know what to expect because the
persona
but he's so down to earth and you'll be
like
you what did i say oh a guy from boston
dan shaughnessy
called him a fraud the other day and i'm
a bossing guy i'm like hey dion he's
like
and you can buy the ball but like you
should dump a thing of gate around his
head like mccarthy's like i [ __ ] hate
that guy
like he he's he's very real very
authentic i didn't know what to expect
but he's uh he's as good an athlete
to interact with i probably have a
handful where um who else is
up there greg olsen yeah i couldn't be
it like he's one of the early guys
but i'm as comfortable talking to you
wasn't he doing the uh
the van talk right yeah he left super
bowl
media day media day because they won't
let us in
to come talk to us in the van early and
by the way
there is nothing like i'm a huge loyalty
guy
like i really really appreciate the guys
who were with us before we blew up in
in or before they blew up and stay with
us um
goes a long way and i'm the same way but
it is crazy like i went to a party the
other day
in the hampton is no big deal but it was
like i walk in and blake griffin was
there
he literally like grabs me and like just
he's like i love barcelona
just grab me we went up and shot the
[ __ ] in a room for like an hour it's
surreal [ __ ] like that yeah that that is
it was still stunning the point when i
realized like this is no longer
bar stool of i think that everyone grew
up in college whatever ron was
uh the joe burrow or coach o whatever
interview
i was like wait what that was the first
interview that they gave how the [ __ ]
did this
yeah it's great you know we've always
been with the athletes
very strange because athletes
unlike espn where they're out and asking
athletes like ask to come the ones that
do well like kevin hayes
who's had an unbelievable season for the
flyers
like i'm legitimately very good friends
with these through the system
and it we got to the point kind of what
you said a lot of the guys who play
sports now or in the pros
they grew up with us like they were
reading it in like high school
so the the they're like fans and then
they know we're not out to get them like
we're never trying to get
out of people like gotcha quotes we're
trying to be funny and interesting give
a different look and they appreciate it
but i think that's also
why you guys are so successful right
it's like media is shifting now to
nobody cares about what does
x you know network how do they take what
i said
manipulate it take a quote and put their
spin on it
like i just wanna hear what you say i
just wanna hear what greg golson says
whatever and you guys
just created platforms where they come
down and we're protective like i mean
kevin hayes like for example we got a
video sent to us he didn't do anything
wrong he was just making a ruckus and
like a chinese food restaurant
it was very funny i was like dude like
clean it up like we're not gonna post it
just heads up so
you know we're not it it we're not out
yeah we're not team guys
yeah we're not out trying to make people
look bad and we're also
one of the few places especially
nowadays where like
we don't really apologize for hey you
like to drink beer and like go [ __ ]
chicks like that's like frowned upon
somehow now
like we don't it's like all right we're
guys like
we're not we're not bad we're not what
everyone's just authentic
correct it's just like literally this is
what i would do if the camera wasn't
here so like if you want to watch watch
if not then
that's always always the [ __ ] that i've
heard the negative about me they're
always
like if he says this on camera imagine
what he says off camera it's like
that that's the [ __ ] point like
you're getting
as unfiltered that's why you're mad to
begin with is because i literally said
the worst thing i was gonna say
right right and that's it like there's
nothing else i'm talking as if we're not
on camera that's how i am
all the time i've always said i like the
people i don't like
there's people who've come through the
walls and it's like oh i like this
person
i don't like this person this person is
cool put a camera on me
yeah 24 7 you're gonna get the same
exact person
24 7. there's a lot of people
probably not like that all right i got
three questions to end it yeah
biggest regret you have over the last 17
years
i really don't have money i've been
asked this before and it's like
i started one company it's this i
did i have like irrational confidence
because like
maybe other people would quit or
whatever but everything
i seem to do has seemed to work it's
been a dream
i mean i started a company in my
basement with no money delivering
newspapers
and got here i would have been happy
making 60 grand a year honestly it
wasn't about money
so it's hard for everything's worked so
i don't have
business i have i have no regrets all
right side note
real quick the espn van talk yeah
controversy what happened so
that that was an interesting point in
barstool
because part of my take blew up
and espn wanted them basically and
we're at a point probably dan and i more
so than pft where he's looking
his open market value was more than what
he was making here it's like
kind of like everybody's like how am i
gonna you know this is my moment too
so espn wanted them i was never
comfortable with the deal
but uh essentially what happened
was and the we did that deal why we
agreed to that deal was to like
basically okay we can't test it see what
happens not only test it we got to let
them like stretch the legs and grow they
wanted it dan and pft really wanted this
deal
um so it's like okay we'll we'll try to
make it work
and at first espn just like wanted to
call it
like van talk no bar stool in it they
essentially what they wanted to do was
test drive
dan pft yeah contracts would be up in a
little bit it's like
they knew they could probably pay them
more and it was very obvious to like
myself and eric like we know what you're
doing
so you if you're going to use our talent
you better [ __ ] call it barstool van
talk so we did fine
this was like a year in the works net i
was never comfortable with it
um i always felt like they thought it
was dirty but we get there
and i don't know a day or two
after it launches the first episode goes
first episode it was a hit
it did well okay i mean they put it on i
forget it was on like midwives or
something in the morning on espn2
um so they put it on they didn't even
give you espn they gave you espn
it was just smart because you have our
audience who's gonna watch it and and
honestly
those two guys are as talented dan's
like
the most talented hard working guy there
is so that he's got
everything he does work so it would have
worked um
and then they cancel it they issue a
press release i be
but i believe or no we found out that
they were canceling it
and it all stemmed from i talked about
sam ponder with dan
years and years ago in barcelona it's
locker room talk
and we had a podcast pikmin podcast
which we still do it's like 10 years old
we'd call each other up and we were
talking just about the games which we
always did
and and sam ponder just had a kit and
she was toting the kid
all over espn game day and we were
talking about game and and i
and we were both going back and forth
was like you know i don't want to see
sam ponder's kid on game day nobody does
i'll die
on that hill it's like young who wants
sampara is super hot but nobody wants to
see
it's like an all guy show the reason she
was hired is she's very attractive knows
football
another thing i sometimes get in trouble
it's not coincidence most sideline
reporters are attractive doesn't mean
that's the only requirement you have to
be talented but you have to be pretty to
look at
so it's like talking away it's like i i
i don't want to see her and her kid on
the sideline anymore and i actually said
she has to stop being a prude and [ __ ]
it up
that's what i said i'm assuming she
didn't like that
we didn't know she didn't like it okay
we didn't even know so they were so
that's an
important point you guys never had any
interaction okay
so but but obviously understandable why
she didn't like that totally yeah
and i've said this about her in a
respect
first of all it's not calling someone
[ __ ] i said it's semantics i went back
and looked i've called
my sales guys i just used the word a lot
it was different time it was a free word
you could use
but i was being like we you you go stop
you stop being yeah so whatever i didn't
call her it's like you're being i said
the opposite she's got her kid and like
but three years passed four years pass
and
the show gets launched and she starts
according to the
press reports the crusade against us
being like we're going to business with
these guys who said this
about me four years ago i didn't even
know what we said we said it a lot
so that in that actual respect
i i was like i do respect sampara she
held the garage for four years so i was
going to say yeah she's a dave porter
she
she waited for the moment and she came
in guns ablaze and and sank it in in the
quote that john skipper had kill shot
yeah yeah and this the quote john
skipper
had was i didn't know that people would
associate the parcel sports
barstool van talk with barcelona sports
he literally said that
by the way like two weeks later resigned
coke addiction best thing ever
popping champagne bottles did i was
gonna say you was that your uh
you had a bottle so the sam ponder where
where i differ from sam ponder
because that part we set it i have no
problem with it
she then made up things that i didn't
say
and just blatant lies so i can say i
just said what i said and
i once say now and she actually the
stoolies being who they are
went back and dug up like a thousand
tweets of her
calling people [ __ ] and [ __ ] similar
language she apologized like
it's like i've changed as a person it's
definitely a different world today than
it was even five years ago
and that's always like dead spin who who
you love
you despise and are the first ones to
throw stones at me in the past
they deleted their entire twitter
history all of it and then they'd be
like we changed
i have always said i won't delete any of
my twitter history it's
all there it's an open book i've said
what i've said times are different
i wouldn't say it most of the [ __ ] that
people dig up on me now
is five to ten years old and they were
meant to be
and it wasn't bad at the time mostly
there might be one or two that people
get very upset about right and
rightfully so but for the most part
most of you there's nothing i ever have
said
that was with the intent to make people
truly feel bad unless i hate you
but then i won't use that one like the
things i say that are trouble are people
i don't know or like just in
conversation like in a locker room
environment if i despise you like ross
gerber
i'm saying things to wound you on a
professional level
but like the sam ponder thing came up so
organically
and we're like talking i would have said
it in different way but the point like
nobody wants to see your newborn every
single week in all your segments on
college game day i would say like that
did did that show getting cancelled say
[ __ ] we're not gonna play with the
networks anymore
pretty much okay that's what it looks
like yes
and you don't need them i think tv still
matters
okay and i would love a network our own
network but like we do the barcelona
sports advisors which i think
is pretty much the best football show on
tv we tried to buy it
for the internet like literally built
for the yeah they tried to say
that we couldn't swear in it like we
like to beep out the words
they're like you can't swear like all
right we're not running we're going to
keep it fresh
um it it'll come around i think
everything will come around i mean when
i did the
is tv ready for like what i'll call the
internet content
like how you use the green screen you
have all the graphics like
tv's ready for that definitely okay and
it goes backward i mean again you look
at everything he did get in trouble
like you know people just pick and
choose the hypocrisy of everything which
drives me nuts like jimmy kimmel man
show and
like that almost if we did that and he
did get in some trouble for i think
blackface but if
he if i did the man show i'd never stop
hearing about it ever i never get jaw
and
people what i say and do even though
we're very clear comedy i've always said
what people say about us is you go into
a comedy show you don't have a ticket
you don't know who the comedian is
you hear a joke you don't like you go
into the street you'll be like you never
believe what this guy says and you give
no context to where you heard
that's what i feel like people do to us
i don't know how it started i don't know
what it is
because i think a lot of people now do
kind of similar stuff to us but when we
say it it hits different
i have no idea why you just get uh
almost labeled as people are people are
waiting for you to say something and
then i double down i get in fights like
i don't back down
i'm never like oops sorry i shouldn't
have said that it's like [ __ ] you that's
like a joke if you can't take it
but is that not the right way to handle
it like like in terms of there's some
people who
say something and they would immediately
backtrack and almost like apologies
yeah and then the crowd or the mob wins
right versus
if you say something and you mean it and
you just stand the line yeah i get a lot
on
twitter and anybody like hey when's he
gonna learn you're idiot why don't you
do this i turn around it's like
why would i change what i'm doing
because it's what got us
here you know it's like barcelo
is as successful or more than i ever
dreamed
by being authentic and just being kind
of myself and by the way my friends
i'm like just a combative person and
even
like kevin who's sitting over here is
relatively new like
i'm pretty mean and straightforward and
then i forget about it like
five minutes later like that's how i am
people can come in and like yell at me i
don't really care
that's just that's my personality that's
fair
yeah are you gonna buy one percent of uh
net worth and bitcoin
i'll get back i've been saying i'll get
back in bitcoin all right i don't know
what i mean
like i so you should you should do it
and then just wait till the end of next
year
i you know you can't look at it because
you got weekends like you'll sell it
that somebody made me like a mini pair
of mittens
like i love the weekends did they did
they they sent me did you did you see
all the uh
the replies to the question i asked
yesterday i said what should i ask them
50 of them are just asking how does he
how does he eat with such weak hands how
does he
listen everyone thinks i'm like some
the the i know i knew i had to be
involved in crypto
within like 15 minutes of starting to
see the respond like oh these are kind
of my people
and the best memes like that vin dog is
good
well vin dog's the best i mean
if you go if you go vin dog versus
bitcoiners who who wins the meme
dog i don't know they're relentless
they're it's one man versus an army how
many
live-action memes have you seen from the
bitcoins
listen if you if you put the challenge
out categories if you put the challenge
out then the bitcoins are gonna send you
live-action memes
and they're and you're going to
literally run out of money hiring all of
them for
live action i listen they are good
vin dog is one of the best oh vindog is
right on the perfect line of you can't
tell whether he's serious always because
his actual memes are all like super pg
so it's like he puts your face on like a
baseball and hits like a home run
himself like there is no answer for that
there is no answer for the vin dog
he's out in his yard like drop kicking
his son and that's probably why we in
the
crypto like i don't know how many of
them have actually like
know who vin dog is or sorry but there's
very few people on our side of the world
like when i saw vin dog like i knew it
was higher like oh my god i have a
nuclear meme weapon
sitting here it's like well i need this
guy instantly hired
we literally he was a shop teacher that
we hired
um he's like what about my associate all
that's like dude just you're gonna make
memes for us and kill people
but no the crypt i
uh somebody who's about to get social
security out of taking social security
to come make memes for part
teams like a lot you've been a shop
teacher for like 40 years
um the yeah i'll get back in my finances
are so weird it's like
i i do like knowing what i have i have
so much influx with penn
um in my own day trading account like
you you cannot answer this but
what do you do you just keep a bunch of
cash or is it all in pen
no i i have so you strike me as a guy
who's like
super risky with a majority
correct but then you're also like i
probably should keep more cash than most
because i know i'm
crazy and will do crazy dumb risky
things i'm pretty much pushing at all
times like i uh
so i have my own day trading account
which is now about even so i was down
three
i was up four and now i think right now
i'm like dead even because the last two
weeks i've gotten lost like four mil
um and then i have a pr
like uh investment that i'm not like day
trading
but if you looked at what it is it's
still
pretty risky and i just like buying pen
because it's like me is that what it is
all pen yeah no i probably have like i
have like pen
i have amazon oh so it's stock portfolio
correct okay
yes um but i don't have much like
liquid really it's all invested yeah
you're not sitting with like 10 million
dollars in
bank account i'm sitting with like
nothing in the bank accounts all
invested
it's all invested which by the way is a
smart strategy right now given the fact
that they're
going to devalue the dollar and ask well
i don't know it's the
it depends who you talk to everyone says
no but i mean again i'm young enough so
it's like i'm not
what are you 42 43 so like amazon i
don't care if amazon goes down it's
coming back like the amazon's [ __ ]
what's basically shopify like those
you had an amazon warehouse in your uh
apartment correct yes so
those thoughts i have zero
zero fear or anything like that of um
you know the ones that i'm risking on
like the the energy cars and
[ __ ] like that not the teslas but like
the younger ones and even like i said
i don't think anyone knows this space
the gambling i
will be safe but i think the majority
it's a race to the bottom for a lot of
the
i think there'll be a ton of
consolidation in the online gambling
space
that's fair uh last question every
saturday dominoes
mainly because it's just super you do
every saturday
every saturday for real for real where
do you live
in new york 44th and 3rd what do you do
what do you mean what like you're
sitting here with me
like i saw your like domino's is
it raises credibility
it does if that's like what you're
eating well i was what i was going to
ask just every saturday one meal
and i was going to ask where i'm
assuming that you've done a pizza review
for it
domino domino's yeah it's not good no no
that's why i raised credibility issues
what what do you mean do you remember
what you ranked
how many times do you think you'd eat
dominoes last year
over under five dominoes it's
domino's stock outperformed amazon the
total on behalf
well it was the pandemic was very good
no no the last five years
oh five years really donna's
outperformed amazon
crushed it crush is impossible i'm going
to show you a
donkey outperformed amazon i don't
believe here's why
because the mobile ordering they've
absolutely
crushed it i don't believe that though
all right well when i show you you're
going to go buy domino's stock now
here
look at this [ __ ] chart
dominance well you're showing me stop
but that all right that's a good chart
but i still
that's from 2010 to 2018.
so eight years absolutely crushed amazon
apple facebook and google
so you didn't answer though what do you
do what's your do a bunch of stuff
all right what invest build a company
what company i've got a whole digital
content thing
okay so right now these these are vague
so are you like a professional
well i'm here to ask you questions well
no i'm that's what i'm trying to figure
out like what
what is it uh so i've got a couple of
funds
right that i invest all early stage
technology
is that what you say professional
investor yes i invest what's like your
net worth are you rich
huh rich enough are you richer than me
no okay but where'd you make your money
at
where how investing and then starting
like you just took your own money and
started oh no
i did other things i worked at facebook
and other places stuff like that too but
uh and then i've got a uh podcast got a
email
on it right now you're on it right now
correct top 10 tech podcasts in the us
got it and uh there's obviously very
good business to be in
uh that's what by the way i always like
the ross gerbers of the world do you
like him
huh i i i'm cool with everybody he's a
[ __ ]
well and a used car salesman but i love
guys like what'd that guy do
what guy is he just uh but here but
here's the thing right so
what did he ever do like guys like that
who chirp at me it's like dude what are
you talk like he like what you have to
remember
but so here's the thing a lot of those
guys you got to remember they have built
businesses it's just not the type of
business
what do you build well i'm saying he the
place that he built right
is an asset management firm now it's a
completely different business than
actually selling products or doing
anything like that but
it's always a weirdo who can't do teach
like what is this quote he said at me
where uh
today this guy this guy really got
underneath your skin well someone when
you were coming in i saw somebody tweet
at me be like ask him a girl because
he's on your show
oh yeah he came on the podcast a bunch
of the finance guys have yeah because
right you know why those guys need
[ __ ] publicity
because they gotta [ __ ] sell their
junk bonds to [ __ ] unknowing old
ladies and steal their pensions
you realize that their uh their argument
back would be that you're trying to get
people to gamble
totally but i'm honest about what i'm
doing yeah but like that's that's also
why
it works this this ross gerber pen
gaming issued a ton of stock as we
called that secondary from a mile away
penn is out of money with 41 bleeding
casinos they used
pump dave to pump the stock and now the
dump that's
that's just a blatant lie that's an
absolute lie did you respond
uh my response was hey ross remember
when you begged me to come on your
podcast
i stuffed you in a locker all right you
deleted it he did delete it
because you a used car salesman who lies
and cheats and deletes whenever they're
wrong
you should be in jail for stealing hard
people's life savings with the
screenshot
he did ask me to come on he's like come
on my podcast i was like hey
hey i have an idea suck my dick you
realize that
people in finance are not used to that
type of reaction well this guy
this guy thinks he like i don't have a
memory
like he called me an idiot for not he
literally
he's all right so the only reason i know
who he is he reached out to me
he's like basically in so many words
said you're too dumb to invest your
money give it to me and i'll invest it
i've seen plenty of people like you make
money and blow it it's like who the [ __ ]
is this guy
so i said i like talked about it
basically like
who the [ __ ] is this guy and by the way
if you're out on twitter trolling
for people to invest that's not who i
want to invest with
i want to invest with people who i have
to whine and dine
them that's who i want to give my money
to is like no we don't want your money
your money is no good here
like that's who i want to get my mind
not some [ __ ]
junk bond guy who's like hey give me
your money on [ __ ] twitter to a rando
who would ever give your money to that's
not how it works like
you gotta find somebody who's so
exclusive that they don't want more
people
not [ __ ] ross gerber do you have
anyone who manages any of your money i
have one guy but it's like a collab
issue yeah all right but so you're not
doing it all yourself
good no i have a guy like jp morgan yeah
that's who like helps oh
you you like work with the suits at the
bank that column a suit
you probably but again it's the same way
like so in an endearing way
yeah there there's somebody who like
do you send him emails hey suit will you
if the socks are down like the suits you
you and your suits you're [ __ ]
killing me but
he's actually been more conservative
like you should sounds like no we're
[ __ ] pushing push push me
but uh like i saw there was a guy i know
who started a hedge fund like through a
friend or friend
and it was the same words like i'll try
to introduce you it was hard to find
somebody who's comfortable with
not [ __ ] this guy who was wearing
rent
rent-a-tux
on the [ __ ] social media begging
people
hold on go back to domino's for a second
you don't remember if you did a review
or not
i actually thought it but i think it's
pizza hot i don't think i've ever done
it
yeah i don't know i'm telling you you
got i'll order the pizza i had dominoes
no no lately sober
no yeah exactly if you eat it sober
you're gonna be shocked
stocks outperformed uh for review all
right you do a dominoes doesn't mean
it's good
well people keep buying it yeah but that
doesn't mean it's good
it would you keep buying shitty pizza a
lot of people would buy like there's
plenty of [ __ ]
but do you no i don't right but
i mean you could use there's plenty of
stocks of food stocks i probably don't
like that
like kentucky fried chicken which i
actually can't but fast food mcdonald's
i don't like mcdonald's
oh that's blasphemous makes me feel bad
i mean i like the taste i don't like the
after effects well that's fine
yeah but you enjoy it when you're eating
it yeah of course that's what makes it
great
all right that's it guys appreciate it
thanks